herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen runde
hunger games geht sofort los die seit
über die arena einige sofort gestartet
und ich habe gar keinen plan wo hier
irgendwelche kisten sind ja okay dass
damit die kisten sind dass es irgendwie
logisch ich hab ein holzschwert ich habe
meissen schwer das ist killer
natürlich ich habe ein diamant schwer
das auch ganz gut ich glaub mich wird
keiner angreifer und wenn mich angreift
dann schlage ich einfach zurück ich hab
grad kurzzeitig gedacht ob ich hier so
eine art challenge akzeptiert raus
machen also ich habe gesagt dass ich so
eine serie machen werde wo eben immer
sachen die kommentare schreiben könnte
und ich werde da dann versuchen diese
sachen umzusetzen so was wie zum
beispiel auf die ganze zeit rückwärts
oder nur um f5 modus oder nur mit
schwertern schlagen und sollen ganzen
kaffee wieder alle auf mich drauf aber
ich habe einen diamant schwert das heißt
[ __ ] euch schickt euch los [ __ ] euch
dem es auch gut so wahrscheinlich kann
ich halt mal richtig punkten welt ohne
wissen der menschheit zu finden das
natürlich schon krass so erst mal sieben
acht leute getötet wohin wir auch schon
wieder eine krasse runde
ich bin mit seinem google wenn du das
liest der welt cool drauf also wir sind
ganz herumgetollt und nachher man mit
letzten überlebenden im komischerweise
gegen alle getöteter probe relativ
schlecht waren
jedenfalls war es dann so dass am ende
nur noch weiter übrig geblieben sind ich
hab gesagt er soll mich töten weil am
anfang schon ein stein statt geschenke
nur deswegen haben wir nachher dann so
abgeräumt
weil wir beide dann so team gemacht habe
ich kannte den gar nicht allerdings über
das recht anständig schillig und jeden
fall nicht sprinten doch kann ich m
können wir dann sind wir dann am ende in
seinem wasser dingsbums gegangen und ich
wollte mich umbringen und er hat dann
erfordert mitunter gestellt und ich so
nah was geht blabla und ich wollte
eigentlich dass er so diese spiel
gewinner punkte bekommt weil der die
ganzen mir schon geholfen hat unseren
sonntag und am ende hat der mich dann
also wir standen unter wasser
links und die hat mich dann am ende
daraus gekriegt deswegen war es dann am
ende so dass ich dann diese punkte
bekommen habe also das war echt ein sehr
sozialer sehr netter und allgemein sehr
cooler mitspieler so dort wollte ich ja
ganz gut sagen so jetzt mal ganz kurz
das hat weh getan jetzt mal ganz kurz
zur team junger ich habe es verstanden
als man ganz kurze
challenge accepted serie habe ich ja
schon mal erwähnt ich muss mein leben
wieder regenerieren habe ich ja schon
mal erwähnen vor längerer zeit hatte ich
so was gern starten möchte ich habe
gerade chinesisch gegessen war danach
ging joggen das war keine gute idee war
jetzt habe ich kratze bauchschmerzen
jetzt sind die ja noch hinter mir kommt
das erstmal tot
ich muss das machen damit ich mich jeder
ein bisschen generieren kann
ich war dann jedenfalls joggen und ich
habe jetzt total bauchschmerz 80 grad zu
hey ich hab morgen zur fünften stunde
weil sport bei mir ausfällt sport habe
ich mit stefan an alle die es
interessiert oder liegt killer
brustpanzer auch schon habe ich mit
steffen wenigsten interessiert und
deswegen am entfall blablabla irgendwie
sowas und deswegen dachte hey komm ich
nur ohne hunger games auf dachte ich mir
so herr kircher theoretisch man die
erste folge gibt ihm raus nicht geht die
woche menschen jetzt konnte sich in
einer mit dem das projekt mehr kann er
theoretisch die erste folge kommt den
beschützer jetzt eben hier die ihr die
erste folge channel except daraus machen
und zwar das ist eine serie wo ich in
hunger games eure challenges sage ich
mal bewältigen werde
zum beispiel wie ich gerade schon gesagt
haben die doppel f5 die ganze zeit
spielt also die ganze zeit nur so rum
laufen oder halt nur so rum laufen oder
mit 11 8 rumlaufen weil also die ganz
halten so dass das so langsam ist oder
mit f1 also ohne steuerkreuz oder
irgendwie nur mit der faust geschlagen
oder einfach gar nicht schlagen
versuchen ins finale final ich werde es
aufgabe hd.de carl machen
jedenfalls werde ich das halt dann immer
so versuchen das könnt ihr mir einfach
in die kommentare schon mal so ein paar
challenges schreiben wenn ihr wollt dass
ich so etwas mache und alter sich krass
aus der himmel wenn ihr wollt dass ich
so etwas mache und dann werde ich mich
daran mal dran setzen also erwartet dann
nicht täglich sondern ja ja komplett
churchill ich will hier die bahn jetzt
kommt er hier von der seite konflikte
weg
so könnt ihr euch die sachen nimmt ihr
die sachen hier kommen noch ein eisen
schwert für euch so danke dass ihr mich
gerettet habt ohne die hätte ich das
glaube ich nicht geschafft
so hat er sich jetzt gefreut war der
dass der gail geschrieben hat ich weiß
nicht ich finde sowas eigentlich immer
ganz gut dass man sich in hunger games
unterstützt eigentlich ist es ja eher
gegeneinander weiß geht mittlerweile
nicht mehr dass man wirklich mal
gegeneinander ist wie immer leute team
machen
ich war immer langjähriger kämpfer für
die these games jeder-gegen-jeden geht
mittlerweile nicht mehr so gut denke ich
bin selbst erlebt oder so ich mach das
nochmal wenn jemand schreibt so
irgendwie oder mich auch anschreiben
stadt so luca vorgezeichnet so ich
fragezeichen
ich erwarte mir dass wir jemand lacht
aber dann hab ich eine kamera allerdings
mir so ich bin schon echt einfach spaß
so dich noch eben hier wollte ich weiß
gar nicht ob das schaffe weil ich noch
doch das war relativ simpel hat er
hinten helm gehabt er besser als meiner
jacke jeder hier ist besser als meiner
fähigkeiten habe so habe ich noch etwas
hier was ich mir noch ausrüsten können
nämlich gar nichts mehr
ich will aber nicht diese diese ganzen
sachen liegen lassen klasse von nur mehr
sachen liegen das war sehr logisch von
mir gerade aber naja ich brauche viele
pfeile werden ich geil ich habe das ist
gut so dann kann ich ein bisschen rum
schießen also accepted ihr könnt mir
einfach sachen die in die kommentare
schreiben wie zum beispiel schreibt mal
wenn ich du wäre würde ich bleibe
trainer cus kamera wenn ich du wär ich
bin ihnen die total hält das ist wegen
diesem warte guck mal ich die das runter
ja okay bin jetzt nicht so krass wie hat
doch so sieht man es so sieht man griff
dies ist um so gut nur drei übrig
ja soll ich jetzt von hinten irgendwie
attackieren oder wie wollen wir das
machen
ich meine irgendwie asozialen muss ich
jetzt machen nein
wenn die wüssten ja auch schade aber es
tut mir leid dass ich meine aufnahme wir
sind ja jedenfalls okay da hinten sind
die ihr könnt mir einfach so kommentare
schreibt wenn ich du wäre würde ich
gerne mit der 5 laufen wenn ich du wäre
würde ich die ganze zeit nichts essen
irgendwie sowas und dann werde ich
eventuell bald x challenge accepted
machen oder wenn ich du wäre ja nie
wissen wer dich glaubt schon accepted
ich bin dem namen challenge accepted bin
ich irgendwie cooler
hast du mal bock mit sohn nach einer
games zu zocken
ich muss euch gerade erst mal abknallen
hier
wer's feil und bogen king
ach man ja okay ich nicht ich weiß alter
linie krass viele sachen liegt sogar
diamant brustpanzer
ich brauche noch vernünftige ursache die
habe ich auch noch hier drin eigentlich
bin ich relativ gut ausgerüstet aber da
liegt mittendrin ein 1 1 im brust- helm
komm ich zeig dir jetzt mal hier so ich
will diesen eisernen brust helm haben
gebt mir den eisen brust teilen los
das ist ja kein eisen busse ja ok
er macht alter mitten in hunger games on
screen okay leute das geht
so will ich achte er der date seine
sachen aus
ach mensch erwarte aus sachen ausgezogen
hier war ein killer screen ja gut spiele
habe ich auch nie von uns gemacht so
hasst es jetzt dann zieht man jetzt
wieder an so gut ich habe zwei eine
diamant schwerter wie machen wartet
jetzt kürzeste komische runde ich das
gewinnen es gut dann habe ich hier auch
warte was ist meine statistik sp 55
spieler übrig 18 fails acht spiele acht
übrigen sieben gilt 75 tode hilft oder
hier habe ich fünf wurde
doch kraft zwei runden gespielt hatte
burgen ja ach da unterliegt man drogen
wir haben einen bogen menschen
altair ihn krass viele sachen das sieht
immer heftig aus wenn diese viele items
rumgammeln also ich glaube ich würde
jetzt einfach herunter springen weil ich
meine pistole aufgefüllt jakl aufnahmen
zum sport also ist wahrscheinlich
relativ langweilige unglaublich wollte
ich das eigentlich auch nur ganz kurz
verkünden mit den schönen accepted
machen übrigens mein junger leute ist
unter den letzten real video halo kann
deine haare sehen um gemacht für geile
aus deswegen dachte ich mir zu hey nach
dem duschen kann ich als sommer eigene
runde auf den wenn ihr meint das ist gar
nicht so schrecklich aussieht
so sind die irgendwie bessere pause
brauche definitiv ja okay das ist auch
ganz gut
passen diamanten springen braune hose
ja ich weiß er kann sich jetzt in
diamant amish nehme was eigentlich es
war relativ egal meine ich bin schon
ganz gut aus dem account war übrig ja
man spitzhacke alter sind bei comma die
punkte krasse sachen den anfangs kisten
drin das ist echt krank
vornweg mensch also ich finde besser
fast besser ausgerüstet kann man nämlich
an zahlen wollen wir beide in die wahl
gehen und gucken wer er stirbt
ja da eine mohrrübe
ja das war ein witz schild mister bauer
von der bauer
kummer nur weil ich jetzt mit dem
screenshot gemacht habe hey ich kenne
masken also nochmal freundes komplett
privat ist sie immer mehr leute die mir
ihre skypen ampere nachricht schreiben
oder so skype ist privat ich hab da
leute drin die bombe um gespielte ein
paar freunde aus der schule mit wegen
schulaufgaben skype com ist aber leute
von youtube mit denen ich eigentlich
nichts zu tun habe die nehmen ja nicht
kriegt zweimal voll vlan frage wohl
eigentlich keine ahnung woher die
allmend profil kennen nein
also am liebsten würde ich dir ne zum
bringen allerdings komme dieses mal ganz
gut wenn ich den umbringen ermöglicht
hat einst bringe ich den um habe ich ihm
gezeigt ok fick dich ich will nicht mit
diskreten allerdings ist es auch sehr
sozial welche vorhin mit ihm der als
sachen gegeben so was alles wenn ich
jetzt in die lava geht es für mich
schlecht weil wir keine punkte bekommen
allerdings kaum ein gesicht ist voll rot
wegen der lava du bist gestorben
danke fürs mitspielen ich gucke dahin
nicht hell weil das hier so wales hält
ist und jetzt stehe ich glaube das ist
krass wie sich mein wie sich meine dings
veränderten gesicht
gute freunde ich würde sagen dass war
eine runde halbe gamer hd.de plötzlich
gefallen dürfte einfach ein daumen hoch
geben schreibt unten da unten in den
kommentaren meine hände sind immer voll
komisch aus ihren ideen zu groß außerdem
objektiv schreibt in die kommentare so
was wie hält man rasen scheiß schreibt
in die kommentare so was wie du habe ich
nicht da bin ich nur rückwärts laufen
haben wir nicht wären würde ich nur ein
fenster offen wenn ich dann würde ich
nur mit der faust geschlagen so was und
dann leg ich mir dann kommt heraus dass
wir dann challenge accepted 1 da
versuche ich das umzusetzen und dann
würde ich sagen das war eine nächtliche
runde es ist gerade halb elf ich weiß
noch nicht was ich machen soll ich denke
ich wenn wir wieder call of duty jetzt
installieren weil wenn ich morgen
wirklich um 11 uhr mesz aufstehen muss
dann muss das wirklich irgendwie
ausnutzen kennt ihr das einfach
eigentlich wenn ihr am wochenende um elf
zwar schon müde seid ihr wisst einfach
nicht was ich machen sollte seit
freitagabend ist eigentlich immer so
nahmen da geht jetzt nicht ganz so viel
samstag jede menge aber wenn
freitagabend enix geht und jakob lorber
keinen bock auf feiern und ihr seid eine
zu hause dass es trotzdem aus nutzen
wollt weil wochenende ist und ihr könnt
lange aufbleiben dass es da noch
ausnutzen wollte das ist bei mir
eigentlich immer so
nicht immer aber wenn ich irgendwie
freitag feiern wir uns am sagt angelina
oft ab dann ist es samstags mal so dass
ich schon zehn oder so müde bin
allerdings ob ich dann immer noch viele
frauen macht dies und guckt mir ganz
viele youtube videos an nur einfach um
dieses wochenende im ausland zugleich
weiß danach die fünf tage bereue ich das
also sonntag montag dienstag mittwoch
donnerstag die abende die bereue ich das
dann wiederum
na ja also ich würde einfach sagen sind
beim nächsten mal freunde mehr als spaß
gemacht ich find's wieder witzig und
dann sehen wir uns beim nächsten mal
tschüss